♪ ♪
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT IS SAID
TO BE CONSIDERING PUTTING
VENEZUELA ON THE LIST OF NATIONS
DESIGNATED AS STATE SPONSORS OF
TERRORISM.
CORRESPONDENT KEVIN CORKE
REPORTS FROM WEST PALM BEACH
WITH THE PRESIDENT JUST TOUCHED
DOWN ON WHY VENEZUELA AND WHY
NOW?
>> IT WOULD BE THE STRONGEST
SIGNAL YET THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS WILLING TO
TARGET THE OIL RICH BUT
FALTERING SOUTH AMERICAN COUNTR
COUNTRY.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" CITING
UNNAMED SOURCES ASSESS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS PREPARED TO
ADD VENEZUELA TO ITS LIST OF
STATE SPONSORS OF TERRORISM, A
DESIGNATION RESERVED FOR
GOVERNMENTS ACCUSED OF
REPEATEDLY PROVIDING SUPPORT OF
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM AND
INCLUDES IRAN, NORTH KOREA,
SUDAN, AND SYRIA.
IF  TO HIT THE RENEGADE NICOLAS
MADURO REGIME WITH ONE OF ITS
MOST POWERFUL TOOLS.
IN A LETTER, SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO IS URGED TO PROTECT
THE AMERICAN HOMELAND AND OUR
PEOPLE FROM THE VENEZUELAN
DICTATORSHIP'S EGREGIOUS SUPPORT
FOR TERRORISM AND NARCO
TRAFFICKING.
CITING THE ONGOING NATURE OF THE
DISCUSSION WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS
REFUSED TO SAY WHETHER OR NOT
THE DESIGNATION WAS A FOREGONE
CONCLUSION.
A SPOKESMAN NOTED THE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONSIDER IT
SCALABLE OPTIONS TO PRESSURE THE
MADURO REGIME TO RESTORE
DEMOCRACY IN VENEZUELA.
UNDER MADURO, VENEZUELA HAS
SUFFERED HYPER INFLATION, FOOD
SHORTAGES AND A DEVASTATING
MEASLES OUTBREAK WHICH BECAUSE
OF EMERGENCY MIGRATION WHICH HAS
NOW SPREAD INTO NEIGHBORING
COUNTRIES BRAZIL, ARGENTINA,
COLOMBIA, ECUADOR, AND PERU.
CRITICS QUESTION THE WISDOM ON
APPLYING MORE PRESSURE TO A
REGIONAL POWDER KEG.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE AN EXPRESSION
OF ANGER THAT WILL NOT ACHIEVE
ANY OF OUR GOALS AND MAKE LIFE
WORSE FOR THE AVERAGE VENEZUELA
VENEZUELAN.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS
APPARENTLY ASKED HHS, THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY,
AS WELL AS THE CDC FOR INPUT ON
THE DESIGNATION, THE QUESTION
BEING CAN THE U.S. HIT MADURO